what's going on there citizens the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today Brooklyn 99 I got 99 problems but
John ain't one he is two of them oh
ladies and gentlemen leave a like for
John's problems today
so we would like for each problem
specifically full length Reaction watch
alongs where you sing it with your own
copy of Brooklyn Nine-Nine available for
all those awesome people who made
themselves extra by becoming a super
sexy reject on our patreon page cover a
bunch of stuff exclusively over there as
well with reaction highlights and watch
along is included all right ladies and
gentlemen hope you enjoy this video
leave a comment as well anything to help
grow these Brooklyn Nine-Nine reactions
because we gotta be honest it doesn't
get to a certain point soon might just
have to end up getting them got to be a
lot of a lot of honest gotta be lonest
with you
that's the person who is uh abrasive
towards Lawns
alrighty let's do this man don't get me
near grass boy
the food in prison was inedible all I
thought about day and night were the
things I wished I was eating anyway I
thought about you a lot sex with you
just us doing sex with foreplay great
safe babe thanks
unbutton your pants and take off your
shoes because there's gonna be a doink
load of sodium at Freedom Feast 2017. oh
a french fry Village after that we're
gonna move our adventure over to
Cheeseburger Mountain which consists you
guessed it of turkey burgers I'm kidding
it's cheeseburgers this is kind of just
stuffing you can avoid that but oh and
finally we have a big old Passover
brisket cause you know I love my mom if
you at all take a seat while I make a
toast and the matzah you're gonna get
sick to freedom to you and most
importantly to orange drink
and sex with Amy
sorry should have said that last part
it's okay there's nothing wrong with sex
with Amy I imagine it's quite fun the
funnest no funner sex of the rest of the
episode they're bloated I'm ready for a
case so what do you got a murder a sui a
murder Suey they often follow one
another well you can't work a case yet
you've been assigned to desktop please
don't make me sit behind a desk all day
that's worse than prison no it's not
prison real bad
look I'm ready I'm the same old Jake I
don't know why you have an issue with
this Rosa was happy to comply what if
she jumped off a cliff if Rosa were to
jump off a cliff she would have done her
due diligence regarding the height of
the water and the angle of Entry so yes
if you see Rosa jump off a cliff by all
means
babe you forgot your lunch at home
how was Argentina
it's kind of boring actually although
one funny thing did happen to me
you and I have a different idea about
what a funny thing is right anyway how's
your Boogie
something's wrong he's acting weird
other than normal yes he's not telling
me something well you guys did spend
several months apart maybe it's all in
your head oh [__] be crazy is that
what you're saying
I would never say that not cool Terry my
relationship's in trouble
Terry loves women women be sane
[Laughter]
on it join us Jake you know you want to
we're going to wing [__]
going crazy over here man the only
worthwhile thing I've done today was
take a BuzzFeed quiz about what kind of
onion I am hmm
Vidalia
tell me what you're working on huh
before the stapling starts again please
please I don't know if I should
I need this man just give me a little
taste
grand larceny no
who got robbed sneaker story they hope
you die
oh that was way too harsh there's gotta
be a way to fix it and figure it out are
you serious yes
throw on your file all over the place
Charles really immature you're right
I'll go clean it up yeah
he's cheating on me no I found this
credit card statement there's a charge
for a restaurant called La Palapa two
entrees one flan one plus one flan one
flan
I wasted a year until
interrogate them
that's what I'm holding behind my back
before we begin what are the parameters
of the guessing game how many guesses do
I get is there a time forget it you ruin
everything
I can get off of desk duty if at field
evaluation performed by a member of the
municipal police training Council that's
right loophole high five ah loop hole
loop hole Loop
I choose the evaluator and I choose
Me Bring it on I will good good you're
good but I'm better and I'm gonna Ace
this thing before you can even oh wait
wait what are you writing now write
something good write something right so
good write something good write
something good we're just gonna write
something just stop ready where's goodly
really just stop writing stop right I
must have been good
all he took was a shipment of thousand
dollar limited edition wheezies designed
by wheezies what are evaluating pants
they have a deep bottom pocket for my
notepad and they don't crease which is a
must given how much I squat during an
evaluation okay there were no witnesses
to the crime which is weird since there
was a long line of sneaker heads right
outside the window and you're actually
squatting just uh ignore me
there's a security camera across the
street we didn't see before I have a
feeling our answers are in that footage
Squad five
I confronted pimento about La Palapa and
he lied to me
I can't lend you Department equipment
for personal use a Hitchcock you have
any surveillance equipment Rosa can
borrow you mean my creep cap no prob got
another one in the car see Amy that's
what her real friend looks like
oh it's [__]
does it show everything
sorry not sorry it was a gift from my
deceased father a pencil your dad gave
pretty bad gifts
all my dad ever gave me was abandonment
issues so potato tomato
the line moves down everyone except for
that blue pup tent which is interesting
oh my boy's got a hunch she's got
Bunches of hunches I believe all they
cared about was the placement of their
tent which was right over this manhole
cover it's the sneaker store stock room
whoa how does he do it folks it was a
team effort Boyle humble five You Know
It uh I couldn't possibly
what do you want
how's the pimento Stakeout going has he
done anything suspicious yet no just
regular Memento stuff
we went to lunch at La Palapa and we
shared the blonde oh so you two are
boning now no no the blood's huge mental
just walked up to a woman a female woman
Rosa sister
they just kissed oh no so what's this
about a giant blonde
thank you Morris Richmond yes and are
those wheezies yes
well done Peralta thank you but it
wasn't me it was Steph
the wheezies
[Music]
come on man I'm innocent sure you are
buddy we all know you did it
[Music]
Charleston
we arrested the wrong guy what Morris
Richmond didn't do it we have to fix
this right now
I'll wait for you to not be naked
we arrested the wrong guy what about the
pup tent and the manhole and he was
wearing wheezies maybe his friend gave
them to him just like he said we have no
physical evidence tying into the stock
room plus where are the rest of the
sneakers who's the friend ah those are
our stolen shoes her name is Jenny
McFadden she moves her merch out of the
back of a bodega on Willoughby cool all
right one problem if we go to the bodega
looking like detectives well spooker oh
costumes
I know about your mistress I know about
La Palapa I know about the plan babe
wait oh I've been waiting I waited all
night to do this we're done it's over
what no that woman's name is Senora
Reyes she's my Spanish teacher estoy
aprendiendo espanol para impression
Adrian I'm so sorry you must be so mad
at me are you kidding jealousy is like
the hottest emotion let's do this okay
let's do it
Go kids we're looking to score some
kicks you know where we can find some
yeah the mall the mall what do we look
like Jay and Silent Bob
[Laughter]
tell me what her favorite shoe is
old school Impala All-Stars
okay
I believe that worked I just guessed the
coolest shoe I knew when I was right
nope he's running away
got me where is Jenny McFadden that's a
cover for the dude who steals the shoes
his name is Morris Richmond he'll
definitely pass your evaluation now yeah
the only thing is you let Morris
Richmond go oh no
oh what were you thinking
look when we arrested Richmond and he
said he didn't do it it's just feels a
lot harder for me to put another human
being in prison After experiencing it
myself oh wow
the truth is I'm not the old me yet
damn
poignant
anyways I'm gonna go cry in the room
please
last night when I ended things with
Adrian I had this huge feeling of relief
I need an excuse to end things no I
don't know what to do
I think you do know what to do thanks
Amy
no I have no idea what she's gonna do
but that's the safest way to give Rosa
advice yep
we agree that if you couldn't keep it
together you couldn't be a part of this
I'll be good we went through your case
File and everything we needed was there
and an address in Queens that he used as
a safe house the two seven just picked
him up Tom tell them now
yeah I can't be here
[Laughter]
prison has made you more cautious yeah
but what if I'm too cautious now I mean
I used to see everything as black and
white and now it's looking real gray to
me
so you passed your evaluation you can go
back in the field I think I should ride
the desk for a few more weeks
I respect that you're gonna regret that
decision thank you for understanding
yeah oh
look oh boy
here's your blood back oh
well in that case
I guess you should have your blood back
too what how did you get this you know I
might want a couple minutes up here
alone just to kind of
process this you know do it what so
how'd it go it actually went
surprisingly well
[Applause]
honestly this is the best I could have
asked for not a doctor
oh damn man I love pimentos I feel like
that came out of nowhere no and then why
would you even need to write them out it
was perfect yeah with the [__] they were
perfect
what happened
I mean he could still come back maybe
but I don't know I've learned to not
expect that from episodes that I like
that
I think uh I thought it was like playing
on the fact of you know Rosa with the
kind of personality she has of still
having a difficult time letting people
in it she feels more comfortable being a
loner that was an opportunity for that
that she still has more to grow in and
being in a relationship I thought it was
like going that direction yeah yeah like
what the [__]
Witnesses bummers
yeah yeah he was unexpected that's
that's the best are you bro you broke up
with us now yeah
I loved him he was such a great addition
yeah is he not liked on the show or
something what's going on here there's
some other conversation here that we're
totally missing out because I thought it
was perfect do we only attract the
Adrian pimento fans out of all the b99
followers yeah is there something that
was not to like is he sure for such a
long time yeah and I mean you know the
way that they've orchestrated his
character over time it just made sense
that he would just Bop in once in a
while and it's a nice surprise and yeah
it just doesn't seem like it needed uh
while he was learning Spanish to impress
her I know to impress her dad
I don't know I mean maybe this will come
back but at the same time it just it
just feels pretty finite
that's a bummer real sad I thought that
was it was really strong
uh but no this is a really great episode
it was a really funny episode and they
they had me going to with the I like the
way the twists and turns happened with
um Peralta where it where it did come
down to the reveal of how prison really
has changed him there's not a lot of
times they go through these arcs and
especially like a sitcom off Dodge
Brooklyn 99 where the residual effect of
some Journey that they went on
be played for last for an episode or
doesn't really have a lasting impact
right and this had a
a more real take on what might happen
with a guy like Peralta I mean I like
the
I like these sentiment I have a
publicist calling me right now
um I like the sentiment that is always a
bit of anxiety
um I like I do like the sentiment
that you gotta pick up my thoughts Sir
John what we're talking about uh the
sentiment about Jake you know not
feeling ready and being very affected by
his time in prison and seeing the world
oh yeah yeah great I thought it was um
I like the way that moment was played
where he was saying that he
seen things black and white side because
I'm here like shaking my head like
but the I couldn't quite tell in that
moment if the if the show meant for that
to be funny yeah because they play it so
Earnest yeah with it still kind of like
dramatic handheld looked at Brooklyn
Nine-Nine sometimes does when they're
having a more serious scene
uh
I think there's a humor to it though
just just because his idea of like the
ideal cop fatalities you gotta see
things black and white and be certain
about everything yeah you know which is
a bit of a naive POV especially now yeah
um so yeah I I did like the I really did
respect how they managed to link it to
an actual Arc about oh this is evaluate
it all stems from you know doing an
evaluation and it is like
self-reflective of what he goes through
and he has to mature and the lessons he
has to learn there and I thought that
was actually quite strong
I I was I was impressed with that
because like the episodes the Dual
storylines are both of what they are ex
experiencing posts being released from
prison
um both Rota and
and December both Peralta and Rosa so I
thought this was really strong this is
really strong and the Terry bit so it
was interesting what the Terry bit was
that
I didn't find it
funny when they cut to the flashback in
Japan but everything proceeding yeah
when they got brought up was funny the
lasting effects of that on him you're
just like laughing at a Japanese yeah
that's really funny yeah yeah and I and
I liked um it like you know sometimes
you'll have subplots where you get a
bunch of you know a few different
characters lumped together and and I
thought this was one where like all
three of them in that plot line made a
lot of sense like you know even on the
the Peralta story lines mostly him and
Holt and Boyles is along for the humor
of it all but in the Amy and Rosa and
Terry bit like I like that idea of like
I was helping feed into this for you and
and you know we've both been through
this you know I've been through the
experience you think you're going
through the experience and together we
sort of convoluted our own worst case
scenario and uh and yeah I thought that
was a nice thing plus you get a you get
a nice little involvement for Hitchcock
and Scully in their creep kit yeah
that's true so like every every
character even in the small appearance
is like that you know had a lot of
flavor and uh and yeah I thought it was
like nicely rounded to go from like
professional plot to personal plot in a
way that made sense for the both of them
yeah especially like the Rose's time in
prison doesn't come up a lot in the text
of the dialogue but you know it is one
of those things where yeah like after
being gone for so long and having him go
down to Argentina because of all his
craziness you know like yeah I thought
this was a nice sort of recuperating of
life after person yeah
and uh and yeah just like everybody was
on and everyone's like everybody at some
point made me laugh everyone's like
comedic timing was good but also the
serious things or the more thoughtful
things felt appropriate and not to
preach your shoehorned or anything like
that and like you can see it coming that
like oh yeah him having this realization
will lead to him passing the evaluation
but I thought the way they handed that
too and the whole thing with the guy
with with him like they had him play
that well enough to where you're like oh
maybe he is innocent and then you can
anticipate like they use the format kind
of against you for subversion in that
moment because you're like okay he's
gonna wake up in the middle of the night
and be like the guy's got to be innocent
and then he's not and I thought that was
a nice kind of way to do that too yeah
and I did notice there was a hint of a
moment in the they did capture it in the
scene when he says I'm innocent and my
friends the Andy Samberg does have this
brief little look like they don't do a
close-up on him they don't try to milk
the moment whatsoever but it was like a
little hint of a moment before he died
but they didn't they didn't capture that
in the performance so yeah I thought
that was a really well done episode it
was really funny
um yeah guys what'd you think about it
leave your thoughts down below be sure
to subscribe leave a like helps out the
video and hey we will catch you all that
is so thank you so much